[ __ ] 7 am
on a holiday and then my dad looks at
him he goes oh
um you make you you like drinking right
you make mixed drinks why don't you make
her a mixed drink when she comes over
I'll get you a martini shaker and what
do you what ingredients do you need
what do you want to like Target real
quick or something dude I'm like bro
what is she gonna do [ __ ] walk
through the door at my brothers with the
martini
how are you in five four three two one
Hello everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast I am
your host David so just checking my
phone real quick it was just buzzing off
like a [ __ ] weirdo and we have Ed
Park here AKA and park v p what's up uh
in the last podcast that you guys
probably saw which you know I don't even
know what the comments are like right
now but I know people are mad at me and
guess what
don't [ __ ] care I don't care no more
never care then still don't [ __ ] care
now just a couple of thoughts and guess
what you're allowed to disagree with me
and I appreciate it because you guys are
being honest everyone read it and
everyone had a thought you just kind of
set it into a microphone that's all yeah
you know but I kind of like it when
people
not that I'm searching for it or
anything right but I like the idea that
people can speak their mind and then
they should know that I'm okay with it
as long as you have points to it yeah
right I don't think you're dumb for it I
think it's just different you know
that's all that it is I praise you I
think that you are great I think genius
brain listeners are some of my favorite
people on Earth and when I get to meet
fans who are genius brain listeners they
are they're always the best they're so
good I'm like damn you guys are [ __ ]
dope yeah sometimes I want to bring them
on the podcast
or you might have an attack on Titan
situation yeah
sorry all these inside jokes that's a
previous episode as you know [ __ ] Mr
tiny hands
Jesus Christ man
dude sad story which you know by the
time this comes out I'm thinking it's
already been like a month
past and you know on this podcast I
don't
sometimes I just don't care to talk
about topics when it just comes out yeah
and usually when I do I get all the
information messed up anyways yeah
because I'm only regurgitating the
information that people who are you know
basically like me that are just saying
stuff that they believe to be true at
the time and then later you find out
that it's not true yeah also sometimes
too you just want to process your
thoughts a little more because you just
have more stuff to say about it yeah but
I think sometimes people just want they
want you to talk about it right now but
like hey let me just think on it for a
second so
about a month ago Jason David Frank
passed away right for people who aren't
in their 30s or maybe in their late 20s
uh you probably don't understand what
impact he had on a lot of our lives he
was my [ __ ] hero dude Jason David
Frank if you don't know was the original
Green Ranger you know of the American
Power Rangers
um [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] dude yeah like
he came in as a bad guy and he was a bad
boy and his eyes would cook green it
would creep on the Pink Ranger all the
time dude he was basically Pepe Le Pew
yeah
cool that was kind of Genius of him to
have his own identity in the way he did
his hop Keys too right yeah and then all
of a sudden on the playground everyone's
doing his hotkeys
[Music]
it wasn't the Bruce Lee [ __ ] anymore
yeah it wasn't like that it was like
that Tommy hop and like it was such a
huge thing for us like growing up yeah
when I when I first read about the news
like like I said when when the topic of
suicide comes up it always like freaks
me out a little bit in the sense of um
it's really really true when people say
you don't know what somebody else is
going through you just [ __ ] just
don't right yeah like you know from an
outside perspective I think prior to
people talking about mental health like
the instant reaction is
this person had so much to live for if I
was in their position I would never
because there's so much things to be
grateful for but you can't tell people
to be grateful for things that they
don't see themselves yeah right and who
knows what he was actually going through
um when I thought he died I thought it
was like from some type of action or
whatever yeah car accident something and
then I was thinking wait how old is he
like he's not he's in his later 40s I
think it was like 47 or something 47 or
maybe even early 50s which is really
[ __ ] young right yeah and the cool
thing about Jason David Frank if you
guys don't know and I was still
following for a while not on Instagram
but just kind of following him here
they're just checking up on like my
childhood Heroes here and there he
actually did MMA right I've seen that
yeah MMA at like light heavyweight he
was like 205 pounds fought this guy who
wasn't that good himself but either way
it doesn't matter he was in a [ __ ]
cage and he was a pro fighter and he
[ __ ] armbarred the [ __ ] out of this
guy and beat him it was amazing like I'm
watching he actually did it yeah we're
watching this TV superhero actually do
it in real life which you don't [ __ ]
talking seat yeah like pretty [ __ ]
cool a lot of us would have killed to
see like um I wonder how Bruce Lee would
have done in the cage yeah I wonder how
Jackie Chan or Jet Li would have done or
Donnie yeah Donnie I'd love to see him
in the cage for real yeah but then our
Power Ranger did it you know what I'm
saying yeah that's [ __ ] dope so
apparently he was going through a
divorce with his wife yeah yeah and his
wife was the one that found him dead
right I I didn't read into it so like I
I was up one morning and then just
looked up the Twitter trendings Jason
David Frank yeah okay you know I I
clicked it and then it was like all
right PRP but when you keep scrolling
like uh early news was like it was
suicide but everything was such a rumor
but when I saw suicide I put my phone
away like I could not I didn't want to
read further into it I think like I read
into he was going through a divorce but
as far as from that like I I had to put
it down like uh broke my heart I mean
here's a quote from her so my name is
Tammy Frank and my husband was Jason
David Frank who tragically lost his life
to suicide last week while Jason was a
well known name to some we live the very
normal life with ups and downs just like
anyone else that has shocked us had me
beyond belief to see that the media has
turned my family's tragedy into a tall
tale since Jason's death I have been
harassed online and can no longer stand
to watch my husband's good name be
slandered I love my husband and we were
trying to work through our problems his
death comes to shock
to me as anyone else the truth is I had
no idea that Jason was thinking of
ending things yes he had struggled with
mental health issues and depression
before but I could never predict what
would happen that night it was meant to
be a fun weekend getaway and instead I
lost the love of my life Jason was a
good man but he was not without his
demons he was human just like the rest
of us we initially planned to separate
that part is true oh so they were on the
birds getting divorced however that is
the only part of the story the part that
has been told is that at the time of his
passing we had called off our separation
and we're in the process of reuniting
don't get me wrong we had ups and downs
and many troubles during our 19 year old
marriage but this was especially hard an
especially hard year for us a year ago
my daughter Shayla whom's Jason helped
me raise in his own suddenly passed away
wow Jason had been the one to find her
when it happened and the situation erect
our family emotions between losing her
and helping raise her baby's son Jason
and I started having marital issues for
anyone who has known the pain of losing
a child I know you understand how such a
loss changes things in your marriage
however about six weeks ago they decided
to rekindle their romance after a close
family friend helped us realize that we
still loved each other and yes we
shouldn't just give up yet
uh as part of their plan to reconnect
Jason planned a two-night getaway in
which the two attended a country dance
uh dancing event something Tammy says
Jason knew she uh he loved to do we
danced and stayed out at the event until
the bar closed when we got back to the
hotel Jason and I were having a
heartfelt and emotional talk in his room
to help Jason relax and sober up before
turning down to sleep I went downstairs
to get a snack from the lobby I must
been gone no more than 10 minutes I went
back upstairs and began knocking on the
door to no answer
I knocked repeatedly and kept calling
first name to open the door
oh my god oh wow she's she's not saying
at all I don't know if the hotel staff
or a guest called the police but after I
was taken downstairs by the police they
were able to open the door and found
that Jason took his life
uh she continues these were the
disturbances that has been brought up
numerous times online all we want is to
remember Jason oh concluding your
statement Tammy asked that people stop
making assumptions and leave my family
to grieve peacefully all we want is to
remember Jason in our happiest memories
and move on from the pain of losing a
loved one I only ask for sympathy and
understanding during this difficult time
to all the fans and supporters of Jason
and our family thank you for your kind
words and we wish uh and God bless you
all
that's [ __ ] nuts
um yeah I kind of heard about this I
didn't want to misquote it that's why I
just kind of read the whole thing so you
guys can kind of hear uh if you're
listening to this online but so
essentially what happened was that they
went on a couple's getaway to rekindle
their you know failing marriage that
they're trying to fix and he decides to
do it at on their getaway he commits
suicide he kills himself in the room and
she was trying to come into the door and
he locked it and he killed himself
man that is that's [ __ ] heavy yeah
how crazy is that [ __ ] that's wild I
mean like no more than 10 minutes
than just getting snacks like that's
yeah I mean how did you do that you hung
himself or I don't know what he did but
he took his life in that bedroom and
locked it so yeah she couldn't come in
and this is after they just had a
heartfelt talk and they opened up to
each other that means he was planning to
do it
yeah geez how [ __ ] nice is that you
never know you never know like you said
earlier like what somebody is going
through in their heads and such but
you know um for a lot of people too
especially if you've had suicidal
thoughts and such like
um it's important to know that there are
people that love you and care for you
um it's also important to know like you
know but what about five years from now
would you want to do it kind of thing
it's also important to be aware like
do you want to really hurt yourself and
kill yourself or are you going through a
tough time and you just don't want to
exist anymore yeah like you don't want
to commit suicide but you feel like
dying you know and that's a very deep
thing to have to deal with um with a lot
of people who struggle with these things
the tragic part being the fact that his
wife was there with him they're wrong
anyway and it's like maybe there was
just a
uh the point of no return
kind of thing like when you say he
planned it where it was like this is how
he wanted it to go you know what's
interesting
um
so
I was actually kind of shocked but
Barton Geo and I could talk about this
because they talked about it openly too
but uh Barton Geo talked about his dad
did you see that I just saw the post the
other day it was like I was late to it
and then I just saw I was like oh my God
that was a shocked at me too yeah I mean
not that I knew them or anything but
yeah it's tragic yeah and you know I
didn't listen to the podcast so I'm not
gonna go into details about so basically
what happened was uh I was in uh Hawaii
at the time right
uh we were opening up June B uh Waikiki
if you guys are in Hawaii check that out
um and I get a
a text from Bart and Bart's like hey
like uh something crazy happened in my
life and I need to talk to you about it
and I was like oh yeah cool hit me up
and just like in Bart's [ __ ] fashion
this jackass was like I'll hit you up
later and then it just leaves me on red
for
[ __ ] like 10 hours I'm over here like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] is it you know
because I'm freaking the [ __ ] out Bart
never says this type of [ __ ] yeah I'm
freaking the [ __ ] out I'm like [ __ ]
kazeki this [ __ ] would say
something like hey this is this is some
crazy [ __ ] that happened to me I need to
talk to you I'll talk to you later yeah
why did you just message me when you
could talk to me you [ __ ] dick he's
just thinking about you yeah and so
finally I was like hey are we gonna talk
he goes oh yeah yeah I'll call you like
an hour so he tells me about what
happens with with his dad right
um
no his dad passed away yeah right and we
all know how he passed away right he you
know committed suicide yeah
which I was a little surprised that you
know he was so open about it because I I
wanted my headspace and I was thinking
I don't think I could do that yeah I
don't think I could tell people about
that yeah
um
but you know everybody deals with their
stuff differently like I'm not him and
he's not me
um and I don't know what their specific
relationship was we only and you know
for you guys too you only get to see the
relationship for what you see on the
online
um so I'm not gonna get into too many
details about that type of stuff but you
know when I thought about that [ __ ] too
like you know afterwards we talked on
the phone I was in Hawaii and you know
that should still like trips me out
because this is the man I've met right
and if and if you see Bart's dad or if
you've ever had the opportunity to see
him
you know it goes back to that thing if
you don't know what people go through
because he smiles a lot he's always
laughing and [ __ ] like you don't know
what the [ __ ] he's thinking but he's
always smiling and laughing
and I could only think about like how
especially as an older Asian man how
[ __ ] lonely that must have been for
him
how lonely is that right especially
because
um
and I'm pretty sure Bart has talked
about kind of like what his dad did to
even come into America yeah it was a lot
right so he's basically at the Finish
Line his dad's older and then even then
through all the stuff he'll still decide
to take his life so as as a person from
the outside I'm just trying to like wrap
my head around like what the [ __ ] was he
going through that nobody could even
sense this type of stuff yeah his own
son you know his ex-wife his his
daughter-in-law like nobody [ __ ] knew
and
I didn't know nobody knew yeah and then
he still decided that life wasn't worth
it even when he's right at the Finish
Line yeah he well he has what another
like 10 15 years maybe and it wasn't
that wasn't enough to keep him alive
right he has a grandson he has a
grandson that he's always wanted and
even then that wasn't enough so
if you kind of look at their journey and
I was thinking the other night it was
like damn he went
he moved to Vegas right originally and
then Bart was the bottom of house and
then
um
he didn't like Vegas yeah left there
went back to LA
and then that's where he decided to take
his life
so I'm thinking from my position and
perspective of like trying to figure out
what caused this and you know I'm never
going to know but it was like maybe the
signs were there that nobody really
could see because we didn't we weren't
looking hard enough because
his son very successful he sees this
relationship that he has with his
grandson he's like this is a beautiful
thing goes to Vegas his son buys him a
house everything is laid out for him
he's still not happy he goes I want to
move back to LA he goes back to L.A he's
still not happy
there's nothing that's really satisfying
him and he's kind of at this you know I
think like too when your job's done as a
parent your life goals are now complete
and now you're just kind of left with
your own thoughts maybe it's like your
regrets things that you wanted and the
things that you want to do because
you're older you can't do anymore
so maybe he was left with that Despair
and then nobody knew it he didn't have
anybody to talk to because he's an old
Asian man yeah how [ __ ] crazy how sad
is that [ __ ] yeah yeah I I thought about
that exact thing that you're saying
right now when my dad passed
um
he passing asleep
um it was like a major Cardiac Arrest
kind of thing but even still looking
back in the last years of his life just
the idea of loneliness struck me very
hard and the the thought of how lonely
he must have been
was my head for a long time
you know
um because of you know I I sit here and
like I tell these crazy [ __ ] stories
about where I grew up where my stories
you know
um and the real thing that I looked out
there about like how I was affected by
it was also extreme loneliness you know
and for sure yeah
the the thought really broke my heart
that
um
the fact that my dad was a poor English
speaker and didn't make friends didn't
have friends I believe was so far away
from any like real Korean Community kind
of thing
um yeah that's why it became important
for me to to you know do the best I
could to have a community in the idea of
a community make sure I had friends that
had my back as well and such but yeah
um
it's it's still like very confounding
like and I don't think we'll ever
understand
um why somebody would make these choices
yeah for them and the weird thing too is
like when I think about his father and
you talk about your father I think about
my dad I'm like dude this guy's [ __ ]
embarrassing though yeah yeah I think I
like that sometimes I'm like
some of these guys have like such tragic
stories and look at my dad I'm like you
need to chill bro you [ __ ]
embarrassing because I went back to um
like I love my dad but you know this
kind of ties into what I'm talking about
because you know you know my mom says
about my dad too where she goes you know
sometimes your dad to me I look at him
and he's like the saddest person on
Earth and I'm like why I was like
because he wants to be so close to you
but he does everything he can to push
you away yeah you know so his version of
what he does to keep us close does not
do that like for example I'll give you
this [ __ ] so you know I went back for
Thanksgiving right and my dad is
somebody who loves us so much he tries
to help us in any way possible no matter
how [ __ ] annoying and inappropriate
it is yeah right so
back at home there's these uh people
that we grew up with right uh grew up
with in the sense that they're kind of
like in the same neighborhood type of
thing and I didn't know these these
these uh two kids there right these two
girls because our age Gap at the time
well still now it was like four years
and like six years right well when
you're younger that's a huge age Gap
right so I'm a senior in high school the
other one's like a junior high that was
in elementary school so I knew them as
those girls that would hold each other's
hands they would be chilling on their
driveway and there's only a few Korean
people in our neighborhood
so
my parents get this Bright Idea my dad
he goes I'm gonna hook up your brother
with that with one of the girls there
right because now they're in the 30s
yeah and then without even asking my
brother if he even cares to yeah let me
tell you how [ __ ] awkward my dad is
okay
so I'm like the the medium in between
all this other [ __ ]
and my dad
it's like oh we're all gonna have dinner
together because my parents got really
close were their parents over pandemic
yeah and so they're like okay I want you
to meet her and then my brother's like
okay I came here I didn't get a haircut
I didn't bring any [ __ ] clothes yeah
he goes well we just didn't want to like
you know set you up with anything he
goes no
I didn't bring anything yeah it's the
opposite
and he goes okay fine and so my dad I
shoot you not in the [ __ ] morning
this is what he does
it's like 7 A.M my dad just comes into
my brother's room turns on the lights
close the door and walks out
what and my brother's like what the [ __ ]
what are you doing why'd you do that he
goes oh she's coming over today yeah at
2PM it's a [ __ ] 7 8 A.M on a holiday
and then my dad looks at him he goes oh
um you make you you like drinking right
you make mixed drinks why don't you make
her a mixed drink when she comes over
I'll get you a martini shaker and what
do you what ingredients do you need what
do you want to like Target real quick or
something dude I'm like bro what is she
gonna do [ __ ] walk through the door
and my brothers with the martini
let's party let's party
you look like you're a martini girl like
what
dude why are you so my brother's getting
pissed he goes what is the logic behind
this yeah why the [ __ ]
I'm just gonna walk up to her you like
mixed drinks what what are you talking
about and then my but that goes you
should take care of your skin here you
want me to you want me to massage your
face to you what's on your face today
what it's like has he ever so I looked
at my dad I was like dude you're making
this worse yeah number one you'd even
tell him about her number two massage
his face oh you're an esthetician now
yes
what was he gonna be there when they
were meeting so I was like hey what have
you used lotion ever what do you know
about lotion he goes I'll massage his
face for him I'm like with those [ __ ]
sandpaper hands of yours you're gonna
rip his [ __ ] face to shreds don't
touch him oh my God and I'm just like
taking and I'm taking my parents aside
I'm like what are you doing what are you
doing you're making this tent first of
all you're acting as if they're married
yeah you don't even know if they [ __ ]
like each other they've never met each
other they haven't even met her
hmm what the [ __ ] this is gonna be so
weird this is my [ __ ] father dude
yeah and so the whole so we're all
having dinner together and we're talking
whatever and by the way she's super cool
my brother's super cool it's all have
it's all a good time and then before
we're about to leave you go let's all
take a [ __ ] picture together I'm like
why uh Jesus Christ Christmas of
everything that's good and holy why are
you doing this as we're about to take
the photo right guess what my mom does
she starts pushing the girl into my
brother oh my God and then I'm just like
please stop doing this could you imagine
how [ __ ] this is like the Hail Mary
right now it's almost time I was like go
ahead go ahead just stand next to him
and I'm like what are you doing like hey
why don't you get him some condoms too
[Laughter]
dude and then okay so she leaves right
and already my brother's here I'm
irritated for him but my brother's
taking it pretty well at this point but
I know he like my brother holds things
in and then he explodes later I'm not
like that I addressed it on the spot and
so my brother's in the room and my dad
comes up he starts shaking his hand he
goes congratulations it's like for what
for what congratulations
congratulating him for
because
nothing happened
for what this is this is my father yeah
the most embarrassing man on Earth and I
just looked at him and I so my mom had
to go talk to him because I had to talk
to my mom because she was doing too much
too but my mom's a lot more reasonable
so you know in Korean I'm telling her I
was like imagine how you're making your
older son feel right now I was like
you're treating him as if number one I
was like you don't even know what if she
doesn't like him
um how awkward is that you guys are
family friends
and then we meet it we meet up now
during the holidays you don't even know
if she like she goes why wouldn't she
like him listen I know you love your son
but he's not [ __ ] perfect okay
like you don't even you don't even know
if he likes her then how awkward for
them yeah man this is like such a
nightmare like [ __ ] conversation or
like situation I have to go through dude
witnessing it was hard for me dude yeah
because I'm always gonna be on my
brother's side you know so I'm looking
at my mom I was like you know he goes
well he's not your brother's not
complaining I was like how many times
have you told me that you get mad at our
brother because he just snaps out of
nowhere
he goes he doesn't snap out of nowhere
he's very patient with both of you he's
so calm and he takes all of your [ __ ]
[ __ ] until he just goes boom and expose
the new Gaslight him and you go look at
this temper yeah as you just drag the
problem through this field of knives of
embarrassment yeah and she's getting
shredded up yeah and then you go why are
you acting like this that was your
problem
he's [ __ ] gaslighting his ass yeah
and so I'm telling him he's like I'm
watching him and he's on the cusp of
[ __ ] flipping out like you need to
stop don't message him don't say [ __ ]
anything yeah of course what happens I
leave
I'm next to my brother guess what he
gets a phone call come on yeah and I
call my mom what did I [ __ ] just say
she was what I was like I'm next to him
right now and she goes oh
that hangs up on me on speakerphone
oh my gosh dude but yeah I mean like
that they don't realize the kind of [ __ ]
they do to push you away too man like
this is becoming an obligation you know
it's like and even if they did like each
other let's say they eventually I don't
know start dating right and they like
each other right yeah they are they will
I told my mom too like I think a lot of
Asian parents or Asian kids kind of feel
this way it's like
when you treat your children this way
you allow for a very unhealthy
relationship to happen where they're
going to start lying to you because they
can't be honest with you because how you
behave yeah what they say you're very
dismissive of you do things in the way
that you want it and it's because of for
you and you think it's for your motives
right it's like oh and they're telling
me Oh it's because I want him to find a
girl and get married he's gonna get
married he dates all the time yeah I was
like you're lying to us right now you're
looking for the girl that you like not
that's good for him a girl that you like
and that's very selfish yeah and I told
them too I was like here's the weird
thing about you guys it's like
like I said a lot of Asian kids probably
feel this way it's just they kind of do
things in the way where like like we
said you do everything to push us away
even though you're trying to keep us
really really close yeah and by you
trying to hold on to us this tight it
creates this [ __ ] Rift between us
yeah and it causes your kids to end up
lying to you about things because they
can't be honest because even if when
they are honest you are you dismiss
you're very dismissive of everything
that they say Mom I feel uncomfortable
because you did that you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
right this is what happened today what
did you do
um this is the rhetoric that happens
between Asian kids I knew this is what
happened exactly you're such a you're
you
would do this why do you lie to me all
the time because you create an
environment where they feel they have to
lie to salvage your relationship they
feel that in order for us to like have a
relationship with them that we have to
lie now because if we don't lie we're
going to argue we're gonna fight because
I already know the moment I say
something you're going to be like Ugh
whatever you know like I came from a
place with a very honest relationship
with my mom right but it came to a point
too where now I am like
at the you know life is better when I
just lie yeah and I I used to hate
that about
like just as a character trait mom like
lying or Liars or whatever so I was a
very honest person to like a fault you
know and at one point this like towards
the last month of me being in Washington
state at my gas station in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere hating this life you
know and I'm just talking about like how
am I supposed to stay here and run this
gas station how am I supposed to do any
how am I supposed to make friends how am
I supposed to do [ __ ] out here right and
then I was like how am I supposed to get
married and then I was like are you
gonna call some Korean girl from Korea
from some family friend to come get
married to me so she can get her green
card and then my mom looked at me like
oh yeah oh [ __ ] I was like you're really
planning this
and then like she was like yeah what's
the problem oh my God everyone's doing
it
everyone's doing it what are you talking
about she's like you found me out yeah
and I was like oh [ __ ] like I'm out of
here that was like one of them you know
I don't speak Korean that well right
like what the [ __ ] how would we even
talk well how are we gonna yeah
[Laughter]
there's something like dude like I uh
came to a point too man like I said with
the honesty right
um just like to preface right now like I
had this major existential crisis with
my faith and my mom is such a hardcore
Christian and her pride in me was the
fact that I I did Ministry like and then
I was like a missionary and all that
stuff like that was why she was so proud
of me that's how religious my mom is
yeah and I was just calling her out like
I was like I don't even think I don't
know if I'm a Christian I don't even
think you're a Christian kind of thing
and once I said something like I don't
even know if God is real right because I
was in an agnostic Camp which I am you
know now
and she [ __ ] lost it yeah she flipped
her [ __ ] mind and she had a laptop on
her lap at that moment she just slammed
this shut and just [ __ ] tossed it on
the ground
boom just freaked out and had to lay
down
because of some like stress attack yeah
and her thought literally the whole time
is like
my son's going to hell yeah
and so after seeing that [ __ ] to be real
and like be honest with whatever I was
like
I'm gonna lie like and so after a time
so now they're back in L.A right I'm
like oh yeah you know you go to church
of course yeah I talk about I was what
I'm saying I meet up my friends and I
come to this podcast right he's like
yeah we talked about the Bible with the
Bible study
it's kind of true yeah I just have to
like say that [ __ ] now you know well I
mean it makes her happy it makes her
really happy because at this point it's
like why stress her out yeah you know
like what does it do
so like that's like sometimes with with
my brother because my mom advises my
brother that way he goes just say yes
just agree but the problem with that too
is that when you kind of like feed into
that with I don't think in your case I
think you're doing it right but like you
know for stuff like with my dad over
here trying to make him into a bartender
that'll get the ladies yeah that almost
like dude you're a dweeb
shut up
shut it
I just I've never my dad's Michael Scott
dude yeah that's [ __ ] Michael Scott
yeah hi I'm date Mike that's that's
that's my dad the the Kingo yeah I'm
zate Mike give me this Cherry stem and
he says
I'm like I don't think my dad has dated
anybody outside of my mom and my mom was
the woman that chased after him so he
didn't have to do anything so he
actually doesn't know how to interact
with the opposite sex he has no [ __ ]
clue that's why he has no dating advice
he has nothing but so in his mind he
thinks he knows how to do it so he's
like yeah when she walks in Baker this
Martini
shut up shut up oh my God be quiet and
shut up
this is my father dude yeah the most
awkward man on [ __ ] he is Michael Scott
from the office dude and I had no clue
until this [ __ ] past uh Thanksgiving
yeah man shattered my image of him it's
like oh there ever it happens to almost
everybody growing up oh [ __ ] my dad's
not as cool as I thought he was yeah
dweeb you know great father loving man
checks all the stuff that's important
but in terms of being like a cool dude
absolutely not man
I don't know it's like I guess because
our parents like never grew up with the
internet they have just no clue what is
appropriate or inappropriate yeah
speaking of old Korean men that don't
know what's appropriate or inappropriate
great Segway eh I completely forgot
about that dude things okay we gotta
talk about it
dude one of my favorite people from one
of the best Netflix series of all time
squid game the grandpa it's got me too
he got me too by somebody who apparently
he inappropriately held this girl's hand
that's just that indicted yeah indicted
by the police for sexual
misconductors
but he's what he says is claiming that
they walked around a lake and he held
their hand yeah
um I feel like there's a little more to
that story I don't know yeah like I I
don't know what's going on there right
yeah and I don't know who to believe but
this I don't know why you holding this
young girl's hand bro
how old is the girl do we know
uh I have no clue let's look that up
look that up because he's like 82 or
something he's old dude squid game
pervert
dude one of the funniest comments I read
was like dude it's like how can you
blame him he thought he heard green
light
oh
I didn't make that joke that was online
listen hey no matter how old you gay are
you perfect you're pervert Yeah and who
wants to see him in season two anyway he
died
I used to get so mad when people like
look at old people and they go oh my god
look how sweet they are you don't know
yeah
you don't know them and then he takes
off his candle head there's a SWAT stick
he's still sweet now yeah he's just a
[ __ ] old [ __ ] now yeah that's all
I think you should go around and beat
their asses but I'm saying like the idea
that you think that old people are just
sweet just because doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense yeah that's ages I don't
see age
[Laughter]
that's a bad that's a bad thing to say
did you I used to hate that phrase too
when it's like I don't see color yes you
do yes you do you're like it's such a
big problem to be colorblind than
acknowledge and I think you said it in
an earlier podcast to celebrate color
yeah celebrate diversity I don't see
color yes you do because if you didn't
see color you wouldn't be bringing this
up yeah you clearly see color there's no
problem with it it's not like seeing
colors the problem is how you behave
around it is the issue the [ __ ] are you
talking about you weirdo and then like
there was a time when like a lot of
white people would say that as a virtual
signal thing yeah like it happened in
college once this guy talking about how
he grew up with this friend and it was
his best friend in the whole world and
then maybe not until last year I just
realized he was black and then everyone
in the class was like rolled their eyes
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] bro okay
die yeah it's like what was that story
expected everyone to just slow clap
yeah cool story bro so many of that kind
of like that kind of instance where
people think like that discounting
somebody's color is the most hum a
Humane thing to do
yeah it's like no I'm like no that's
because you've seen a lens where normal
is just you and everything you talk
about normally is you oh you know what I
forgot my my uh I have a story about
Jason David Frank oh really yeah so when
I was in fourth grade
um
we're just a couple years uh living in
Washington and then we came down to La
like every summer to vacation with my
uncle and cousins and all my family down
here in L.A
and then we were at a one of the parks
up in the valley
and there was this huge film crew right
um this is my first experience with
seeing the real behind the scenes what
I'm watching fantasies and I'm like
fourth grade so I'm like nine years old
or something was this shot in Seattle no
no just in California I was visiting L.A
yeah so it was up like near Sherman Oaks
a Balboa Park okay yeah
um and then the next thing I know I see
[ __ ] bulk and skull
walking down by right where I'm standing
oh I go oh my God Balkan skull and so I
mean so maybe maybe Tarantino's right
about the movie stars yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I knew that was bulk and
skull I was like can I have your
autograph he's like sure do you have a
pen I was like no it's like do you have
a paper I was like no I was like why do
you want an autograph
what am I supposed to automate you so
skull you know how he's always chewing
gum he's like you're happy and he gave
me a stick of his gum that he always he
always has gum on him to chew while he's
filming and I'm like what are you guys
doing here what's going on and he said
we can't tell you we can't tell you
right and so all of a sudden all the
kids in the Park start running around
like looking for crew members asking
like so why is bulking School here are
you guys Power Rangers crew like are you
guys filming Power Rangers or whatever
and they kept saying we can't tell you
can't tell you with a smile on their
face
so we're just chilling whatever
and we knew something big is happening
right
then I [ __ ] see him he's [ __ ]
chasing David Frank
and now this is the thing about if you
if you remember the first uh iteration
of the Power Rangers
Tommy was the green ranger first and he
was the bad guy right and then um he
turned good but then he went away for a
while right and all of a sudden this new
White Ranger shows up but nobody knows
who he is and he's [ __ ] kicking ass
and he's always saving the Power Rangers
from trouble and that the advertising at
the time is who was the White Ranger who
is the White Ranger right
and we I [ __ ] see Tommy I see Jason
David Frank and he's wearing all white
and all the kids are like
Thomas
these Power Rangers right and then we
all got a chance to run up to him and
just say our highs and whatever
obviously couldn't get his autograph you
know and I was like oh my gosh like my
whole life was just like Power Rangers
at that moment in my life and I go back
up to Washington come up to school
everyone's talking about it right who's
new right Ranger and I'm telling
everyone it's Tommy Tommy's coming back
I saw it I saw it it's Tommy and then
all the kids wouldn't believe me and it
was such a big cultural thing I guess
for Power Rangers because even the older
kids the fifth and sixth graders who
think who called us babies because we
would like Power Rangers they were
talking about yo who do you think the
white ranger is and I tell the older
guys and they think that I was just a
[ __ ] idiot yeah then it comes out
it's [ __ ] Tommy is the White Ranger
on TV and I was like I can't believe I
[ __ ] witnessed that yeah I can't
believe like I knew before everyone else
and that could have been one of those
things where I was super interested in
the behind the scenes that was my very
first life experience with seeing
production happen behind you know yeah
and it was for my favorite TV show in
life and it just happened to be going on
the day I was just visiting my family
did you ever go back to them and be like
when I [ __ ] say you yes I wish I
could know all your [ __ ] all of you no
they were like no you did it no you
didn't and you know the kids are like
that yeah but I was talking I told you I
told you Tommy was coming back but and
they're like no that's not what you said
yeah exactly it was all of that and
nobody [ __ ] believed me but if I go
try my like other friends like oh
Tommy's like like church friends right I
found the Thomas the the White Ranger
they're like what are you gay why do you
like Power Rangers kind of stuff they
thought it was a baby I'm like oh it's
different that's so funny I had nobody
to celebrate it with and I'm just now
telling this story now dude but I feel
like third fourth grade you're supposed
to like Power Rangers
um yeah that's what I assume too but man
there was a lot a scrutiny like because
I remember me and another kid like
um I think we were doing [ __ ] with like
first grade class like big brother kind
of thing or whatever and these kids were
playing with these Power Rangers action
figures and me and this other dude were
like
so dope I remember I had to be secretive
about it I had the white tiger the sword
the sword yeah we were too poor dick and
then I had the uh the flute the yeah the
Green Ranger flute thing
I [ __ ] up all those toys I played with
it so much like I played with my toys
dude my brother later in life got the
original Megazord the entire thing
apparently that [ __ ] is worth like a lot
now like the OG OG oh all those like
like uh vintage toys if it's like
untouched it's worth a [ __ ] dude I mean
like this is what Jason David Frank
meant me and us like and what Power
Rangers was for us as we were like a
kids growing up Bethel definitely slayed
a lot of [ __ ]
100 music everybody wanted a good
looking guy dude yeah that fool was just
[ __ ] slain
yeah man rest in peace you know Power
Rangers too I don't think they had like
the same effect uh like they did to us
like Power Rangers were like when the
movie came out remember the movie oh my
God just how [ __ ] amazing shattering
yeah it was Thanos the original one
you went back and like watched it again
no I spent a long time holy [ __ ] the CGI
is so bad but oh man but I that was one
of the very first uh few movies we had
on VHS I watched the [ __ ] out of that I
just remember the fighting was so much
better in the movie than it was at the
TV show yeah like the fight choreography
was [ __ ] good the the cable [ __ ] that
they were using to get them to jump was
amazing and then they became the ninja
Zords and all that [ __ ] yeah it's pretty
funny like when you look at um how many
different iterations of Power Rangers
that they have and we know a couple
Power Rangers Yoshi and them right
um
but like the effect that Power Rangers
had on our generation was completely
different everybody was about everybody
wanted the toys everybody was talking
about it
um and that just it was like Pokemon
before Pokemon I guess yeah it was like
one of those waves that came in who's
owned Saban Saban yeah that guy's a
[ __ ] dick yeah I've only read about
like I've heard terrible things about
that fool he just exploits a lot of
young actors to become yeah I heard he
doesn't pay them [ __ ] they don't get any
money for any of the action figures they
own all the likeness to everything all
of that he's like a bajillionaire it's
like you don't even need the [ __ ] the
money anymore you piece of [ __ ] like
what's wrong with these people man it's
exploited exploit it to this La baby
yeah I mean for him too it's like how
much money do you need yeah like in that
kind of case too also I have a small
little bone to pick with Elon Musk uh
eight billion people in the world uh you
spend 44 billion on this
you couldn't have
I could use a billion yeah
that's crazy just think about it I never
actually did the math on that
he bought Twitter for 44 billion yeah 44
like that that's in itself that is a
number I can't comprehend yeah it sounds
so inflated to me there's no [ __ ] way
it's it's a wonder like
like how much more do you need yeah you
know and he's truly proven like what
[ __ ] you money means where just like it
just doesn't seem to matter to him it's
like a dent in his pocket or Twitter
that's [ __ ] crazy how much money that
that individual has how nuts is that
type of [ __ ] like
the idea that somebody owns that type of
wealth blows my [ __ ] mind
I mean
there's
yeah and at the same time too it's kind
of hard to hear him like really complain
about taxes and [ __ ] too but it's like
it wouldn't even hurt you yeah it
wouldn't hurt you and then we'd have
some good highways here in L.A
hey hurry up and make that [ __ ] train
your list you said you were gonna make
you jackass apparently that's all a big
scam too
so he created that hyperloop thing yeah
so that he could kill the rail system in
California state
because California was trying to create
a high-speed rail from San Francisco to
LA yeah so it would take like two hours
maybe for a one-way trip
and Elon Musk basically created and
spend Millions upon Millions if not a
billion like on this hyperloop thing and
underground stuff
just to kill you want to kill trains
right because they don't use gas either
they are clean energy transportation and
it carries massive amounts of people but
this guy sells electric cars
it's a classic move in the you know
the automotive in this case he's a piece
of [ __ ] yeah he did that because like
look at how La is built we don't have a
good subway system right or public
transportation that's because Goodyear
and all of their influence in the 1920s
and [ __ ] they lobbied and like bribed
the whole city so they didn't build a
Subway here yeah that's why La is built
the way it is it runs on car
transportation
just so like because it doesn't Goodyear
doesn't care what car you buy as long as
you buy tires and you need four of them
for one car it's the most inefficient
thing I've ever seen in my life and like
listen when you guys ever if you guys
ever happen to go to Japan Korea Taiwan
or any place that has like a great
subway system and don't you dare [ __ ]
say New York because it's not New York
New York Subway system is disgusting
this is [ __ ] disgusting it's scary
too exactly like I mean literally you
expect a Ninja Turtle to come out yeah
it's [ __ ] disgusting and people are
like oh just take the subway in New York
no I'm okay I want to there's there's a
bit of a charm where it's like oh man
this [ __ ] is so old and whatever but
then it's like yeah this [ __ ] is so old
it's gross
like when you see how efficient the
public transportation system is in Korea
I understand why people don't need a car
you know like the bus system is so
[ __ ] amazing yeah it's really good
and people respect the things that they
have out there like America is such a
weird country like for for a bunch of
people who you know supposedly has a lot
of pride in this country you sure as
they'll treat the [ __ ] that we have here
like [ __ ] yeah there's a lot of litter
yeah for the greatest country on the
history of mankind yeah like there's a
lot of like lip service yeah you know
like when I see people just throw trash
on the floor like wait don't you care
about this country I thought you cared
about this country so shouldn't you
treat it a little bit the little things
like littering yeah for sure it's just
like damn bro like I'll never understand
like if we had a great transportation
system here it would fix so many
problems I would love it I hate driving
yeah I [ __ ] hate driving if I could
just hop onto a train and like okay
it'll take me there in like 20 or 30
minutes on a clean seat without [ __ ] on
it yeah you don't think I would take
that it's amazing how we don't have
bullet trains and we have such it's like
so much flat land I mean like we we
could like go anywhere the technology
that's out we don't even have like a
dope busing system dude no like trying
to trying to find like an overnight bus
to like say from here to like I don't
know San Francisco right it's like this
[ __ ] Greyhound yeah
careful I [ __ ] hate it dude like I
would prefer if we had
dude if we could just have a dope like
two hours to get into a train to go all
the way to like Sacramento yeah I would
[ __ ] love it yeah the only problem is
is like the biggest issue that we would
have with that is kind of like the
homeless situation yeah
um they opened up a train stop off near
my parents house back at home our homo
situation now in our neighborhood is
really bad because they went from the
other spots and now they travel over
here right there's tents everywhere
right so there's I don't think I don't
know how to solve that [ __ ] yeah it's
it's like uh it's a cycle and such like
I had to take so I I had gotten a car
accident a couple months ago and I had
to take the LA Metro
wasn't that bad was not that bad
although that yes I did run into one
mentally ill person who was screaming
crazy [ __ ]
um it was now I'm taking back that it
was not that bad statement but
it was tolerable dude I had that [ __ ]
happen to me in Sacramento which like
you know my friends were telling me like
the like the mentally ill homeless
situation is kind of crazy on Sacramento
now
literally just walking by I'm dressed up
about to go to a wedding I stopped by a
coffee place some dude looks at me he
just goes yeah you ain't the one [ __ ]
excuse me he was like you yeah you ain't
the one [ __ ] talking to me I'm like hey
bro you just call me a [ __ ] he goes
yeah you ain't the [ __ ] one I'm like
uh I don't even know if I should be mad
yeah am I supposed to fight Jet Li right
yeah he goes keep walking you ain't in
you ain't him I'm like
what okay I'm just gonna keep walking
yeah what the [ __ ] I don't know what the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was about
oh this is some wild people like yelling
at you and [ __ ] yeah I don't know man
like there's all these like things I
want to have solutions for but like when
people talk to me about the homeless
thing I'm like I don't know because
they're people too you know just pick
them up and just toss them aside you
can't do that they're human beings yeah
so that's the solution like the most
fascist idea would create like a
homeless penal colony you know and then
like make sure everything is taken care
of for them but then they would be
exploited and such and then what is the
the other side just give them a house
yeah the idea of like uh or like
converting old abandoned hotels like hot
the season yeah turning that just
letting homeless people live there so
like then what it becomes like a crazy
project housing like where it's just a
cesspool of like unregulated and like do
whatever you want kind of building yeah
and there's also that idea of two of
like people get upset because they work
hard to make sure that they have food in
their stomachs and uh uh you know roof
of their head but then I was like why
would do that if I could just be
homeless
and then I just get food in my stomach
and it would throw my head yeah as long
as you do that instead yeah so yeah I
don't know like I wonder what the
solution for that is because people a
lot of people talk about it and I just
don't have anything I I just it's so
complicated that neither do I it's like
you can say Ubi
um you could probably just the idea like
I said the other whole crazy other
aspect of it being just make
homelessness illegal you know and
there's another thing the the [ __ ]
Olympics are coming to La 2028 oh what
the [ __ ] is gonna happen and the World
Cup 2026. what are they gonna do you
know what are you gonna do yeah we're
gonna put all the homeless yeah
so I mean the the thing is you could
leave them there and say this is what La
is about like this is part of LA because
that's exactly what's happening right
now but every time there's an Olympic or
world event they want to hide them they
want to show them away
I mean and right now as of this moment
2026 four years from now they got to
clean up for the World Cup
yeah I might even think about that [ __ ]
yeah well if it was China they would
just throw them away somewhere you're
right yeah right we're not that we
actually learned about that yeah so it's
complicated and I hopefully that's why
you know people vote for whoever We
Believe will figure that [ __ ] out and
then you just peace of mind go back to
the rest of your life Trump's going to
be president yeah you gotta do something
about the homeless yeah I do
homeless people everywhere
terrible guys that wraps up this episode
of The Genius brain podcast uh you can
catch Ed at parkvp or Bible study at
Momos where he's telling his mom that
he's going to Bible study
yup yup it's just sad to save their
relationship yup and then Jesus print
every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll see you
all next time peace